مثل هذا الإنجاز الخاص الذي يفوز به في
اليابان حيث يعيش أجدادك
وكذلك ماذا يعني الفوز بالذهب بالنسبة لك
في طوكيو وإن كان ذلك في ظل
قيود كوبي كما
كان الأمر صعبًا ، فقد تلقيت الكثير من المساعدة من
حولي من أجل النجاح في اليابان من
شخص تعرفه  أحضر لي الثلج والطعام
لأنه لم يُسمح لي بمغادرة غرفتي في
الفندق ، لذلك كان هناك الكثير من الأشخاص
الذين جعلوا أسبوعي أسهل بكثير
مع القيود
المغطاة وعائلتي ، وقد تمكنت أيضًا من
رؤية أجدادي  قبل مغادرتي مباشرة
، تمكنت من إظهار الميدالية الذهبية لهم
، ومن الرائع حقًا
إثارة إعجاب شخص يبلغ من العمر 85 عامًا كان
على هذا الكوكب وشاهد الكثير من الأشياء
، ولكي تعرف نوعًا ما
تصيبهم القشعريرة وهي تحمل الميدالية الذهبية  كان
حقًا مميزًا بالنسبة لي ، لذا فقد كان علاجًا حقيقيًا
قبل مغادرتي أه
البلد أريد أن أتحدث عن والدك
ستيفان تأثيره على حياتك
كيف ألهمك ورحلة حياته
أيضًا وماذا تفعل  إن فوزك
بالذهبية الأولمبية يعني بالنسبة له أنه ضخم ، لقد
تحدثنا كثيرًا عن الفوز
بالبطولات الكبرى والبطولات الكبرى التي
تعرفها عندما نتشارك بعض
الأحلام ، لكن حلمه منذ
صغره كان أن يكون أولمبيًا أه
ومع ذلك فهو حائز على الميدالية الذهبية.
لقد كانت ليلة خاصة حقًا ،
تعلمون في تلك الليلة أنه
نام بميدالية ذهبية ، ولم أحصل
عليها معي وكان نوعًا
ما يعيدها إلى المنزل ويعرضها
لأصدقائه حتى أستطيع  أخبرني كم
يعني ذلك بالنسبة له وأنت تعلم أنه كلما طال
الوقت كلما غرق
بالفعل وأنت تعلم أننا تحدثنا نوعًا ما عن مدى
أهمية ذلك
بالنسبة لي ولكن أيضًا لمشاركتها مع
فريقي ، لذا فقد كان الأمر كذلك
تجربة رائعة حقًا حتى هذه اللحظة
، ثم قام فريق الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية الذي فاز بالفارس
بتقليص ما تتذكره كثيرًا ، هل
تعتقد أن نجاح أمريكا في
كأس ريدر في مضيق صفير ،
أعني أن الفوز أمر مميز للغاية
ولكني أشعر
أنني كنت كذلك  قادر على  نوع من قضاء بضع لحظات
مع المعجبين هناك في النهاية وأم
أه هم سوف ألوم المعجبين لأنني كنت
مخمورًا جدًا في تلك المقابلة
، إنه شيء في ولاية ويسكونسن أن تصرخ
وأنت تعرف آرون رودجرز ورجاله
دائمًا ما يكون صوتًا صاخبًا في لعبة ميلووكي باكس ،
لذلك شعرت أنه من الضروري
إشراك الجماهير وفقدت مباراتي
مبكرًا ، وأنا من النوع الذي تعلم أنه ذهب للتو
إلى المشجعين وقد جذبوني حقًا من
خلال ذلك ، لذا أعتقد حقًا أنها
مجرد  كان الجو العام
للمنافسة رائعًا حقًا ، لكن
المشجعين جعلوها مميزة حقًا ، كما
يمكنك القول إنك خبير تشوغر ،
لكن ماذا عن الفريق ككل ، ما الذي
كان مميزًا جدًا لكونك جزءًا من هذا
الفريق ،
أعني أننا  إنك تعلم أن
داستن جونسون كان أكبر عضو لدينا
يبلغ من العمر 36 عامًا وهو يعتبر نفسه
كما تعلم أنه يلعب مثل مراهق
ويتصرف كما لو كان في العشرينات من عمره ويلعب
الجولف كما لو كان في العشرينات من عمره ، فأنت تعلم
أنه لا يفعل ذلك.  حتى ضرب رأسه يمكنك المجادلة
لذلك كان حقًا  فريق رائع حقًا
أننا جعلنا الجميع يتعاونون مع الجميع ،
وضعك تعرف كل خلافاتنا جانبًا
واللعب تحت قيادة الكابتن ستريكر
وجميع نواب القبطان جعلوا الأمور في
غاية البساطة